ينضم الينا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمل نبدا بهذا الخبر العاجل وتبني
حماس لهذه العمليه ما الذي يضيفه هذا
الخبر العاجل الى المشهد هذه الليله وليد
هذا يؤكد على ما قد رجحته المصادر الامنيه
الاسرائيليه التي قالت ان منفذ العمليه
معتز الخواجه هو من انشطاء حركه حماس وكان
قد اعتقل مرتين في السابق لمده اربع سنوات
وانه ناشط على حسب ما قالوه انه معروف
الهجوم ووقع في وسط مدينه تل ابيب في شارع
ربما الاهم في مدينه تل ابيب شارع
وصوت
اوضحته الفيديوهات من اطلاق للنيران
وكثافه النيران ايضا التي اطلقها الذين
قاموا باطلاق النار عليه وقتله وحسب متحدث
باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي فان مطلقين النيران
قد جاءهم ثلاثه اشخاص من الاسرائيليين
الذين اطلقوا النار على الخواجه
وقتلوه وانهم جندي في الجيش واخر رجل امن
في وحده امن واستخبارات خاصه تعرف باسم
لذلك واضح بان الاسرائيلين المسلحين الذين
تواجدوا في الميدان هناك هم من اطلقوا
النار لكن شبهه وجود مساعد له كانت قد
اشغلت قوات الامن الاسرائيليه في تل ابيب
لفتره من الوقت
وحاولت ان تقوم بتمشيط البحث لكنها لم
تعثر على احد اخر غير الشاب الذي استشهد
في الموقع وقد دهمت منزله عائلته في قريه
علين غربي مدينه رام الله والواقعه بقرب
الخط الاخضر او الحدود وتقع شرق مدينه
اللد ومطار اللد ايضا وهي اخر الكره
المتاخمه للخط الاخضر بمعنى ان هذا التطور
الذي حصل هذه الليله وهذه العمليه وهي قد
جاءت ايضا بعد عمليه التي نفذها جيش
الاحتلال وقتل خلالها سته في جنين ومن ثم
صباح اليوم ثلاثه
قريه جبع تشير الى ان الوضع في حقيقتهم
متفجر وليس متوتر كما يحاول كثيرون تصويره
لان هناك ارتقاء في العمليات الفلسطينيه
كذلك هناك توسع وتصعيد في العمل العسكري
الاسرائيلي هذه العمليه ايضا اثارت جدلا
في داخل اسرائيل الى جانب مخاوف كثيره
عكست نفسها بما جرى في مستوطنه بيتار عديد
غربي مدينه بيت لحم حيث كانت صافرات
الانذار هناك وتبين لاحقا النبي ان السبب
هو والعثور على عبوه الناسفه داخل حقيبه
في حافله ودعى المستوطنون بان مواطنا
فلسطينيه عربيا كان قد يستقل هذه الحافله
وقد نزل منها وترك الحقيبه وان الجيش قام
بابطال مفعولها هذا مؤشر اخر على ان كل
الاجراءات الامنيه الاسرائيليه المتزايده
والمتصاعده في كافه ارجاء الضفه الغربيه
وايضا داخل اسرائيل
من تنفيذ عملياتهم حتى داخل المناطق وهذا
يحيل الى السؤال عن نوعيه هذه العمليه
رئيس الوزراء وصفها
بالصعبه نظرا لتعقيدات تنفيذها علم يتعلق
الامر بتل ابيب
وتكادت الصوره تكون اكتملت بتبني حركه
حماس لهذه العمليه وانما من نفذها من
كتائب القسام وبالتالي ماذا عن هذا البعث
ما يتعلق بنوعيه هذه العمليه
هذا هذه العمليه هي مشابهه بعمليات حصلت
في نيسان الماضي وكان معظمها في منطقه تل
ابيب وحدها كانت ايضا في شارع ديزنجو
فعندما شنا مقاومون فلسطينيون هجمات مسلحه
وقتلوا عددا من الاسرائيليين في ثلاث
هجمات احداها في بني براق الاخرى في ديزن
في تل ابيب والثالثه كانت في منطقه
الخضيره وهذه العمليه هي الجديده التي تقع
داخل الخط الاخضر العمليات التي تلت ذلك
الفلسطينيه التي تلت ذلك كانت تستهدف قوات
الاحتلال والاسرائيليين اما في القدس
والقدس المحتله او داخل الضفه الغربيه لكن
استئناف ذلك وقوع هذه العمليه هو مؤشر على
ان المقاومه ربما قررت ان تستانف عملياتها
داخل الخط الاخضر وليس الاكتفاء فقط
بالتصدي لقوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين في
الضفه الغربيه اجراءات الامن الاسرائيليه
سواء داخل الضفه الغربيه والقدس او داخل
الخط الاخضر وعلى طول الخط الاخضر ايضا هي
اجراءات مشدده جدا لكن هناك من يحاول في
السجال الدائر داخل المناكفات الدائره بين
نتنياهو معارضيه هناك من يحاول ان يلقي
المسؤوليه على المظاهرات المعارضه
والاحتجاجات وبانها اشغلت قوات الامن
وهناك من يقول بان السبب هو تصرفات حكومه
اقصى اليمين المتطرف ووزير الامن القومي
بن جفير الذي اقال ايضا القائد شرطه منطقه
تل ابيب مساء هذا اليوم وتسبب بارباك
الحاله الامنيه والساحه الاسرائيليه
وبان الخطه التي يعمل عليها نتنياهو
الانقلاب على القضاء سهلت على المقاومين
الفلسطينيين اقتحام قلب تل ابيب وتنفيذي
لهذه العمليه لكن كما سبق وذكرت نحن امام
وضع متفجر وليس امام وضع متوتر
بناء على ما ذكرتها الان والتي ما يتعلق
بان اننا امام وضع متفجر فيما يتعلق
بالحسابات الاسرائيليه ما الذي يختلف
عندما يكون منفذ هذه العمليه بين قوسين من
الذئاب المنفرده كما يوصف او ينتمي الى
فصيل من فصائل المقاومه خاصه اذا كان هذا
الفصيل حركه حماس
المنفذون الذين نفذوا كمستقلين او ما
تصفهم حتى الاجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه
بالذئاب المنفرده او الذئب المنفرد هذا
كان يضع تحديا كبيرا تعترف بانها عاجزه عن
التصدي له لانه لا ينحدر ولا ينتمي الى
فصيل
فلسطيني بعينه الان هذه العمليه بما ان
حماس قد اعلنت مسؤوليتها او كتائب القسام
بالنسبه لاسرائيل فهي ستبحث عن تسلسل
همم انتمائه ووصوله لكنها في الوقت نفسه
ستحاول ان تقول بان هناك ايضا فشل انها
كيف لم تفلح في احباط مثل هذه العمليه وهي
في كل يوم تقتل فلسطينيين وتقول بانها
احبطت خليه ارهابيه كانت تعد لعمليه ضد
اهداف الاسرائيليه حسب تعبيرها مثل ما جرى
بالنسبه للشبان الثلاثه الذين قتلتهم صباح
هذا اليوم في قريه جبع والذين ينتمون
لكتيبه جباعه التابعه القدس الذراع
العسكريه الجهاد الاسلامي ومن قبلهم قتلت
الكثيرين سواء ممن ينتمون للقسام او
لكتائب الاقصى او لكتيبه مخيم جنين وما
شابه الان مع اعلان حماس هذا الموقف بما
انها اعلنته رسميا واعلنت بالامس الاول
ايضا ان منفذ عمليه حواره الذي استشهد في
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين هي هو
ايضا من كوادرها ومن قادتها
معنى ذلك باننا امام موقف جديد قد يتسبب
بتغيير معادله الاشتباك بين حماس وبين
اسرائيل وبين
المقاومه ككل خاصه في قطاع غزه مع القوات
الاسرائيليه والصفت وقلت باننا امام وضع
متفجر وبالتالي
سيناريوهات المرتقبه او المحتمله
السيناريوهات الان هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وهي حكومه يمين متطرف وعنصري
حاولت منذ قدومها ان تظهر للاسرائيليين
وكان هي من سيحقق لهم الامن في ظل استمرار
الاحتلال والتصعيد وصعدت من عمليات قتل
الفلسطينيين لكن سلسله الهجمات الفلسطينيه
التي جاءت ردا خلال الشهرين الماضيين
واخرها عمليه اليوم في تل ابيب هذه
السلسله من الهجمات تظهر بان هذه الحكومه
مفلسه في مجال الامني وغير قادره لذلك
ستتجه على الاغلب ستتجه الى نحو المزيد من
التصعيد لان العقليه التي تحكم بها تؤمن
بانه اذا لم يكفي العنف الذي تستخدمه
فعليه ان تستخدم المزيد من العنف ضد
الفلسطينيين مع علما بان كثيرين يحذرون
بان العنف والمزيد من العنف لن يجرها الا
رد الفعل العنيف ايضا في مواجهته من قبل
مقاومه الفلسطينيه جاء ذلك من خلال
الفصائل الفلسطينيه المعروفه فصائل
المقاومه او من خلال عناصر منفرده او
مستقله تعمل بمحض ارادتها او ما تسمى
بالذئاب المنفرده مثل ما جرى في المرات
السابقه نحن نرى بانه في كل مره يكون هناك
تصعيد اسرائيلي عمليه اسرائيليه في
يسقط فيها عدد كبير من الشهداء
الفلسطينيين بعد يوم او يومين تليها عمليه
فلسطينيه كندا عليها هكذا جرى عندما قتلت
قوات الاحتلال تسعه من الفلسطينيين في
مخيم جنين قبل ان نحوي اقل من شهر وبعدها
بيوم كانت هناك الهجوم الذين نفذه شاب
فلسطيني في قربه الحي الاستيطاني لبيع
يعقوب في القدس وقتل سبعه من الاسرائيليين
وفي اليوم التالي
هجوم اخر في سلوان كذلك يصيب وقتل في بعض
الاسرائيليين ومن ثم جاءت العمليه في
اريحا وجاءت عمليه نابلس لتليها ايضا
عمليه حواره الرد عليها من الفلسطينيين
والان بعد جبع وجنين في اليومين الماضيين
جاءت عمليه بمعنى اننا امام تسلسل واضح
للامور وانها تتجه نحو مزيدا من الانفجار
وهذا كله ايضا لابد من الاشاره الى انه
يعقب بشكل واضح تنصل اسرائيل مما وصف
بتفاهمات العقبه وهو المؤتمر الذي بادرت
اليه مصر والاردن والولايات المتحده
واحضرت اليه السلطه الفلسطينيه وايضا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لكن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه قبل ان يعود وفدا من العقبه
كانت تتنصل وتقول بانها تبرم اي تفاهمات
ولم تلتزم باي التزامات وحتى ان الموقف
هذا اغضب الامريكيين انفسهم فتوجه مستشار
رئيس
مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ومعه ايضا وزير شؤون الاستخبارات في مكتب
رئيس الوزراء الى الولايات المتحده كان
ذلك باستدعاء امريكي اصطداح الامر بعد
التصريحات التي وردت على لسان عدد من
الوزراء وابرزهم الوزراء الذي يمثلون
الصهيون الدينيه
وايضا بعض وزراء حزب الليكود الذين قالوا
بانه لم يقل هناك اي نوع من التفاهمات
الان هذا التسلسل في العمليات يشير الى
هذه التفاهمات ليست قائمه بتاتا ويبدو ان
هذا المؤتمر انتهى مع انتهاء
جولته او مباحثاته وواضح بان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه صاحبه العقليه القائمه على
انه ان الاوان لحسم الصراع مع الفلسطينيين
وفقا الشروط الاسرائيليه من خلال عدم
الاعتراف بهم كشعب له حقوق وانما كقبائل
او كعشائر وتحويل سلطتهم الى الى ادارات
حكم ذاتي او بلديات موزعه على المناطق
اداره الخليل اداره نابلس الى ما شابه
واضح باننا امام سيناريو غايه في الخطوره
وقد يكون اكثر دمويه مما هو عليه حتى
الساعه ارجو ان تبقى معنا وليد وايضا